now today is world menopause day which
focuses on the medical and social issues
women face at this stage in their lives
a recent survey by the British Medical
Society found that more than a half of
women feel negative about their
experience of the menopause and would
like greater support my next guest has
written a book about her ongoing battle
with menopause at the age of 34 singer
and actress Michelle Heaton experienced
surgical menopause as a result of a
hysterectomy she's with us now hello to
you thanks for joining us way they have
on you oh I mean I suppose that this is
endless I think most women who've gone
through menopause you never have the
same menopausal journey everyone has a
very different one anything from mood
swings irritability night sweats days
where it's not being able to sleep mood
you know the the in comprehendible
feeling that you cannot tell the partner
that you with for life of how you really
feel because everything's kind of kept
in the list is endless but not everyone
has the same effects and so women out
there are suffering along because
they're not able to talk about it yours
was an early menopause yeah boy so I
have the Bracker to cancer gene right
which meant that I had a 85 percent risk
of breast cancer and an enormous
percentage risk of ovarian so I
underwent a double mastectomy and a
total hysterectomy at the age of 34 so
that plunge me into early menopause and
my son was only six months at the time
and my daughter two and a half years so
it was kind of a lot to deal with when
you go into it the whole one change of
having new kids and menopause oh you had
a lot on your plate and you yeah yeah
you know it's it's not easy
and not that I would have changed my
decision but I don't want to think the
education of what menopause had impacts
on my life was there I didn't really
know enough about it so the reason I
suppose that I wrote the book and why
I'm talking about it say on world's
menopause days is trying to get women to
talk about it because if we don't talk
we're gonna get it's like people don't
want to talk about the menopause because
they don't know how to deal with it and
they don't know what to say about it
almost embarrassed yeah but I don't but
every woman goes through it yeah said
all every single one of us goes through
periods menopause yeah
Cramps you know the list has ended up
women no offense meant go through but
then our men have to deal with the
menopause on a different level because
they have to deal with us and understand
us and a lot of relationships that I've
seen it broke down because of the
menopause yeah so I think a lot of
education needs to be built up so that
all men are understanding what we're
going through yes last yeah and even men
that we you know are not you know in our
close circle I mean I have been going
through the menopause for I don't know
six nine months and people at work you
know they know for quite sure yeah with
it so if I'm in a meeting I just need to
say well here comes my power surge
because I make light of it yep Jim try
and make people feel more kind yeah to
feel comfortable but then that shouldn't
be our responsibility I think that the
workplace needs to understand it more
and I know that in today at the House of
Commons they are we're talking about in
the Parliament about wills menopause day
and they were trying to bring an
educational method into the workplace so
that our bosses can understand the way
that we're going through because it's in
everyday life we're all you know like I
said every woman is going through it and
it's not just and all the 60 year-olds
woman it is getting younger and younger
a lot of women are going through it in
their thirties and well get whether it's
preventative or not but we have to talk
about it and we need to find solutions
to try and help deal with our menopausal
symptoms as well so what advice do you
give to men in the workplace then who
find themselves in a room with with
women who are going through the
menopause don't laugh be understanding
it's not a laughing matter
as much as you might make hot light of
it in a situation I get that at audience
and and I've done that with my friends
who'd already understand what's going on
but inside we're a little bit dying and
we feel really self-conscious or
irritable hot sweaty and sexy yeah yeah
you know all of you all of these words
are associated with menopause and that's
how we feel you know one minutes the
next and nobody sees that they're not
understanding it so it's really hard to
put into words and so we as women need
to know how to control it and manage it
and men need to know how to accept it as
well interesting modern I find that
modern men deal with it in a much better
way than a young amendment in a much
better way than the nose when one of one
of the guys in
officer to me today you know do we call
it the change still and of course we
don't yes because that was that that was
an old-fashioned word that meant that
you changed from being a woman of
childbearing years exact to a woman that
was old yeah I know the whole point is
to break that to do it's not about a
certain age or back we've been unsexy or
about being all there and there is no
rules to menopause anymore and you're
right it should not be named to change
it's just a word it's like having a
period we're going through menopause and
we just need to learn how to control it
but that but the challenge is not just
physically but mentally can be extreme
as you were saying yeah I mean I suppose
for me going through it so young or
whatever age it's been it's been tough
and I have really the most which I have
really low days self-confidence weight
gain in different areas that I never
even knew existed could gain weight I
think just a hormonal shift in general I
mean I was I was quite lucky I got put
put on HRT when I first started but
hadn't quite regulated things so then I
looked and itself can be a challenge
though it has yeah exactly
you've got a spry increase in breast
cancer yep then likelihood of breast
cancer then HRT is not necessarily the
right thing for you not exactly exactly
so I had to look at alternative methods
so then I went in search for for food
supplements and menopausal food
supplements potential for massage yep
and femoral is really good as well
because it's all natural it's all been
approved and which are great
alternatives for people who can't have
HRT because you're right it does not
suit everybody it's just so it's just
not easy lots of groups around where
people can actually turn or women can
turn to say oh you know obviously you
don't want to really you can talk to
your girlfriend's but are there support
groups in place what about your GP of
course going to your GP or pharmacist I
think a lot of people and forget about
the pharmacist that they are qualified
as well and if we ever need advice to
help they're there to help as well and
as well as you know not bothering but
taking ajp upon appointment but no there
isn't enough help groups which is crazy
considering half of the population of
going through it and then the other half
will be affected by it I want people to
say to me you know what
what are your emotional challenges when
you're going through the menopause I
would say it's like being premenstrual
but on steroids
yes yeah listen I mean that there is no
comparison in general at all for me
I've got an amazing husband and he's
really patient with me but there's still
times where I question whether he's
gonna last the distance because I'm not
myself I find myself in situations where
I look back and I think that's not me I
never used to be that person I used to
be really fun and I never used to be
that dramatic and it's not until I take
myself away from that situation where
look back and think I don't want to be
that person as helpful as hell yeah I
work out a lot exercise a big part of it
your diet and there are a long way bud I
know well I actually think that wine
might have tells me I'm actually nice
over the glass of mine and he doesn't
drink right that's saying a lot right um
look the list is endless of what you can
try it's trial and error yeah what works
for one woman might not work for another
remember they of course the other thing
to remember of course I'm guessing is
that you don't know how long it's gonna
last
yeah and it's different lengths of time
for different women exactly and you know
I think it was about 30% of women who
actually won't experience menopausal
symptoms yeah yeah yeah so it's actually
not gonna affect everybody but a massive
amount of women 95 percent of women
don't take HRT yeah which I find quite
astounding because I thought it would be
the opposite it's because either they're
scared of it or it's just not agreeing
but then do you research there's so many
more other availability across the
counter pharmacists that can help you
with different alternatives see HRT if
that does not suit you
are you coming towards the end of the
metaphors no I mean I'm only 39 yeah so
for a long time